there were a handful of protest marches
in u.s cities last night over the
acquittal on all counts of kyle
rittenhouse on friday
police in portland oregon declared a
riot when protesters broke windows and
threw objects at police there were no
reported arrests
rittenhouse was on trial for the fatal
shooting of two men in the injuring of a
third during a racial justice protest
last year in kenosha wisconsin he
claimed self-defense the shooting set
off another national debate on guns and
race reactions to the verdict appear to
be even more politically charged
nancy chen is in kenosha nancy good
morning
jeff good morning to you 500 national
guard troops remain on standby outside
the city of kenosha but while there's a
small group of demonstrators here last
night there were no signs of unrest
we the jury find the defendant kyle h
rittenhouse not guilty kyle ridnows
cried collapsing onto the table after
jurors found the 18 year old not guilty
on all charges
overcome with emotion reign house needed
help getting back to his chair charges
against the defendant on all counts
are dismissed with prejudice the teen
was facing five felony counts including
first degree intentional homicide which
carried a life sentence
rittenhouse's attorney mark richards was
asked about rittenhouse leaving the
courthouse a free man a huge sense of
relief
for what the jury did to him today
he wishes none of this would have ever
happened a pivotal moment in the trial
was the day ringhouse took the stand and
broke down during questioning
when we prepared kyle and we worked on
his testimony
there were things we couldn't talk about
in my office because it got too
emotional and he couldn't handle it he's
in you know counseling for ptsd the
trial garnered attention nationwide
president biden said he understood the
verdict would leave many americans
feeling angry and concerned including
himself
look i stand by what the jury has
concluded the jury system works and you
have to abide by it the jury of seven
women and five men deliberated for about
26 hours they believed rittenhouse's
claims that he acted in self-defense
when he killed two men and wounded a
third during unrest in kenosha last year
i didn't do anything wrong i defended
myself
during eight days of testimony
prosecutors tried to portray rittenhouse
as an instigator armed with an ar-15
style weapon who provoked the shootings
outside the courthouse friends and
family members of the men who died say
the verdict was unjust i am
heartbroken
susan hughes is the great aunt of
anthony huber the second man killed by
rittenhouse do you think this was a fair
verdict i think they tried
i
i like the fact that
there must have been someone
fighting for us
because it wouldn't have taken them that
long
and as for what's next written house's
attorney says he will likely move out of
this area over safety concerns and that
he wants to become a nurse dana
nancy thank you